Mark: Tag yourself, I'm the penguin walking into the barrier.
Mark: He's... persistent, but just so stupid
Shodleech: Excellent
Mark: I exploded!
Shodleech: I was...
Shodleech: I was not ready!
Mark: You started the game!
Shodleech: (laughs) It automatically starts!
Mark: Hello everybody! My name is Markiplier and welcome to "Can't Drive This" with Shodleech!
Mark: Say hi, and then blow me up again.
Shodleech: What is up guys and girls. It's your Shodleech and today (pause)
Shodleech: We're playing "Can't Drive This", and yeah.
Shodleech: Immediate boom. Well let's click Rematch and see if we can get this shit better.
Mark: You didn't say hi to my guys, though!
*Mark is now sad*
Shodleech: Hi.
Mark: *There* we go. I don't allow no intros here.
Mark: Unless it's mine.
Shodleech: (laughs)
Mark: Alright, go. How do I do this?
Shodleech: Click Rematch.
M: Oh, okay.
Mark: *Th-* Rematch, are we competing or something?
Shodleech: Ah, we're working together.
Mark: Okay.
Mark: *I'm* going.
Mark: I'm going.
Mark: This is great.
Mark: This is going wonderfully.
Mark: This is going beautifully- What the hell is this?
Mark: Skooosh!
Mark: Oh my god! Ah! Place! Place man!
Shodleech: (laughs)
Mark: Place!
Mark: Place something! Ooohhh my god.
Mark: Ohh my god-
Ahh!
Mark: Hehe. If I got stuck in the ground.
Shodleech: (giggles)
Mark: (laughs) I got stuck to the ground!
Shodleech: (wheezes briefly and then laughs) That's- that can happen!
Mark: Yeah. It did happen, and then I died, again. But not bad. Not bad.
Mark: Okay.
Mark: Wait, give me another go and then I'll switch.
Shodleech:  (unintelligible)
Mark: Yeh- so, the basic principle of this game is: *I'm* driving.
Mark: And Shodleech, he is, uh- placing the track as we go.
Mark: So you can see his perspective on the right, and then my perspective on the left as I'm driving (pause) my bus.
Mark: And I'm just going oh so gently
Shodleech:  On the far-left it's telling you how fast your speed could be
Mark: Aaah!
Mark: I didn't get a countdown!
Shodleech: The bottom left... is the minimum it shares.
Mark: Ahh! *Mark is very annoyed* Bullocks!      Shodleech: Yep, bottom-left.
Mark: Bullocks!
Mark: Alright. Let me try to build, I'm gonna blow you out of the water.
Shodleech: Alright
Mark: I have *no* idea how this is gonna work.
Shodleech: Right click is to...
Shodleech: Alright. We clicked switch, now we have to click rematch.
Shodleech: Right click is to... turn the tiles.
Mark: Wh-I, don't.
Mark: You don't even need to tell me how to do...
Mark: Pft whoa-ho-ho-ho-ho
Both: (laugh)
Mark: Heh heh heh.
Mark: That didn't go well for you...
Shodleech: I-I think I know what happened.. I
Shodleech: forgot to set up the gamer mode.. So...
Shodleech: I'm searching the W,A,S,D..
Mark: Right okay, sure, okay go for it. So I'm
Mark: assuming I'm supposed to get to that tile over way yonder way..
Mark: Right? The one with the trees on it?
Shodleech: Yeah but that's just a area
Shodleech: that is there more the less
Shodleech: you just go as far as you can.
Mark: Ok. I'm ready. K go.
Mark: Go x9
Mark: This is goin' cra- (giggles) Ooh my god.
Mark: Ok go. Go. Uh oh.
Shodleech: (unintelligible) Mark: Uh oh x4 Uh. No eh- OH!
Mark: Why'd you go the one way I didn't build?
Shodleech: Because I was in the air, on fire.
Mark: (giggles)
Mark: Alright. Fine. One more go. Gimme this one..
Mark: Now out there by the way I'm building.
Mark: He's driving. And it's confusing
Mark: But it'll make sense.
Shodleech: Well hopefully this works. Mark: Woah. Uh.
Mark: Wait. I'm driving? Why am I driving?
Mark: Wait. I didn- Hu- HI!
Mark: God dammit! (giggles) Shodleech: I think we have to
Shodleech: switch first, -Mark: Alright. Fine.- Shodleech: Switches to invites automatically.
Mark: Fine. Fine. Fine.
Mark: I'm ready, let's do this. Shodleech: Ok. Mark: Alright.
Mark: Blap. Blap. Blap. Blap.
Mark: Woah... Shodleech: Alright this thing isn't exactly
Shodleech: easy to drive.. Mark: Yeah ok, mine seemed fine..
Mark: I dunno what's wrong with you..
Mark: Oh, boy. Shodleech: It's a dune buggy, it's not exactly..
Both: (laughing)
Mark: I didn't see which way you were going there..
Shodleech: I didn't much control
Shodleech: where I was going.. Mark: Right, right.
Mark: Well why is it hard to drive? Shodleech: I think the
Shodleech: Dune buggy's just hard to steer this fast..
Mark: Gotcha.
Shodleech: Alright.. Bottom left is speed for driver..
Mark: Uh oh, don't go that way.. That was.. I made, oh I'm sorry.
Mark: heh- we got all kinds of bogged up..
Mark: Can you even go that way? Oh god you can!
Mark: Hang on, wait, ooh..
Mark: Ok, we're makin' it. Ohh god. Shodleech: (laughing)
Mark: Oh god. Oh god. Oh god.Oh god. Oh god. Oh god.
Mark: Oh god. Oh god. Oh god. Oh god. Oh god.
Mark: Oh!
Shodleech: Well that happened..
Mark: Well that's pretty good! Shodleech: I just noticed
Shodleech: there's gonna be near misses,
Shodleech: Air time, and boost time..
Shodleech: This game's gonna be pretty good once it gets
Shodleech: it's updates. Mark: (giggles)
Mark: It's already pretty good, I kinda like it..
Both: Yeah..
Mark: Sheesh.. You go skoodlely
Mark: doo so quick, I don't have- Uh oh. That-
Mark: Uh, I may have screwed you. Shodleech: Mark? Mark: Oh god.
Mark: I dunno what to do. Shodleech:
Mark: Come back. Shodleech: I can turn around.. Mark: Oh no.
Mark: Oh god, I've (laughing) you off.. Mark: Hang on,
Mark: Keep going. I- Shodleech: You're supposed-
Shodleech: You can- Mark: Believe me, I'm- Shodleech: You hav-
Mark: out of tiles. I have no tiles left. Shodleech: Yeah,
Shodleech: Yeah, I have to land on it.
Shodleech: Let me see if I can actually go above one.
Mark: Yee- Shodleech: If I go fast enough, maybe it'll work.
Mark: Alright, I believe in you.
Mark: Uh.. Shodleech: Full speed ah-
Both: Ey!!!
Mark: Nope. (laughing) Shodleech: Alright.
Mark: (laughing) Shodleech: Right click to ste- turn the tiles.
Mark: Ah, ok. Do- Oh
Mark: Yeah! Turn tiles!
Mark: You said that was a thing I needed to do..
Mark: Yeah, okay. Shodleech: Yeah, that's a very goo-
Mark: Alright I got this y-you don't
Mark: you don't have much faith in me but I have a lot of
Mark: faith in me. I'm pretty sure
Mark: Your-  I know exactly what Shodleech: Oh I got-
Mark: what I'm doing.
Mark:Watch out for the wrecking ball.
Shodleech: Yeah, I'm wrecked.
Mark:Oh-h-h (laughing)
Shodleech: (laughing) Mark: Alright, you want me to try to drive?
Shodleech: Eh, sure. Mark: Alright.
Mark: Alright, here we go.
Mark: I'm
Mark: So ready. Shodleech: I don't think you should be believin- I don't think you should be believing in me..
Mark: What else can I do but believe in you? I'm literally
Mark: driving blind here, there is no road in front of me,
Mark: therefore I have to believe in you at some point.
Mark: (noises)
Mark: Okay, alright. We're fine.
Mark: Jus getting ou- Augh!!
Mark: I can't-(laughing)
Mark: On-Once the bus stops, its like,
Mark: I can't turn around fast enough to pick up
Mark: new speeds.. Shodleech: I think that's why there options on different vehicles..
Mark: No (x5) I'm sticking with the bus. I
Mark: gotta go with the bus, or else you know, there's no point in any of this.
Shodleech: True. And I love your hat. Mark: Thank you.
Mark: I got the mustache too so it's all good
Mark: Ooo nice, nice, nice, nice, nice
twice as nice. That's the wrong direction!
Mark: HWA Both: (giggle)
Shodleech: I did not assume
it was gonna turn that direction.
Shodleech: I did not assume that
Mark: Alright, I'll give y- I'll give you one more try
and then I go back to building. Shodleech: OK
Shodleech: It's always those turn ones that I
have to turn that seem to be
dicking us. Mark: Alright, I'm gonna try to keep an eye
on what you're building so that
I know (pause)
delightfully (pause)
eek eek eek eek
ek- he-he-he
Shodleech: Ya kinda got stuck, I did not
know what- Mark: You could- You could like call
out which direction you're gonna go, but it's too late
my turn to build.
Watch as a pro tells you how to do this. Shodleech: Yeah. Watch as a pro
who's never played this except for today-
Mark: It's okay, don't worry about it- Shodleech: ..my previous
job. Mark: I'm real- alright, left turn
incoming up ahead (pause) rotating.
NOO that didn't rotate! Jump over it!
Jump over it! (pause)
Jump over it!
YEAH! *Mark is excited* You did it.
I'm amazed. Shodleech: (giggles)
Mark: Alright- Shodleech: Dune buggy power! Mark: ..you're doing great
Mark: Obstacle. Narrow road.
Uh, straight ahead. (pause)
Don't get bashed. Keep going.
Diverging path. Shodleech: eh eh
Mark: No that's- that's the water *Mark is disappointed* yeeee
Shodleech: No, I made it over- Mark: WHAT?!
(pause) Where are you? Oh god, you're dead.
Mark: That was pretty good, that was pretty good, not bad, that was pretty good.
Shodleech: Yep Yep, I think we're- Mark: K this time I got it.
Shodleech: -getting better at this, I think we're- we're
absolutely getting better at this. Mark: I think I'M getting better at this,
I don't know what you're doing over there. But
I'm carrying you obviously. Shodleech: Oh oh
So it's all MY fault. Mark: Yeah
Thank you for agreeing. OK, right turn, right turn
No no no, left turn, left turn, left turn. Shodleech: I'm turning
Mark: left- O- OK, alright
hang on, keep going, keep going
Oh!
No, you went left. Alright, one more go
Shodleech: I didn't have much of a choice
Mark: Ah, choices are losers
anyway, you don't need choices, you
just need (pause) victory. I don't know
Alright, left turn incoming Shodleech: That's what subscribers are for
they make all your decisions for you.
Mark: Is that how it works?- OK
go straight ahead
wibble wobble, brick laying thing,
you're gonna have a right turn up ahead
Shodleech: *weird noise*
Mark: Then you're gonna go straight again after that-
Oh you're in the drink. How do you keep getting
in the water? How are you gonna win if
you keep getting in the water?
Shodleech: I wasn't in the water that time, I just ended up going a little bit
too slow. Mark: Right, OK
Looked to me like you were in the water.
OK. Shodleech: Yeah just some- just some person that was time travel
that had me go across my vehicle
and slow me down. Mark: Left turn
Uh oh, saaw- sorry
sorry, sorry. OK go over it
make it forward, you got it, you're doing great
keep going
keep going, keep going, keep going
keep going (Shod: We have this.), keep going, yes
Mark: WHERE are you going???
Shodleech: You can still place underneath me to save
me. Mark: Ohhh, I could!
I didn't even think about that. Shodleech: Yeah
Mark: One- one last try, one last
go with this. Shodleech: One last- yep.
Mark: Alright, forward, forward
forward, for- left turn incoming
K
Uh, trying to get you back
to straight, oo that's weird
Shodleech: Uh, I got a boost!
Mark: That's OK I got ya
K, flamings
uh oh, keep going, keep going
you got this. You got like a windmill coming
up. Shodleech: Don't hit the boing
Mark: Getcha- Oh- I got ya
Oh I had you!
Shodleech: The wheel blocked me
Mark: AWWW
But hey, that was a high score
that's not bad (Shod: That was), that's not bad
Alright. Shodleech: This is becoming amazing
We've lost over 24 seconds.
Mark: That was pretty good, you want to go one more time?
Shodleech: Yes (Mark: OK), we're getting better
at this but, see how the turning mechanic kinda
gets a little confusing on some parts. Mark: It does
it does, left turning incoming. back to a
straight, keep going forward
See you got another turn upcoming
Let's see uh, ooo
shhhooty. Where you going?
Oh boy. Keep going. Shodleech: Send mister-
eh uh. Mark: Keep going. Go fast. (Shod: I got boost.)
Ooo where ya going??
Alright keep going, keep going
K. Oh no, that's not right, hang on.
Go tha- Yes OK. You're doing fine.
Keep going. Shodleech: Well that wasn't right but that was. Mark: I'm sorry.
It's fine. Can you go through there?
HHHUUUEEE I tried! I missed! I missed!
Shodleech: All I heard- *random noises*
Mark: (laughs)
Mark: I new high
score. Not bad, not bad
I think that's a good point to end this episode.
That was pretty cool. Thank you
so much for joining me on this one. Everyone please
check out Shodleech in the description below
Uh, and uh anything else you
want to say? Shodleech: Bubb-kiss
Mark: Bubb-kiss. Excellent closing words so
Thank you everybody, if you want to see this again let us know
down in the comments below. And as always we
will see YOU in the next video
Buh Bye! Shodleech: Buh Bye!
*outro music*
*end of outro music*